I you to a good your video and I think I
understand your concern with respect to
effective knowledge-based regulation of
markets as you know under budget this
week we made clear our intention to
proceed with a common securities
regulator in Canada that will help us
with those parts of the capital markets
that I'm not yet regulated in a uniform
way across Canada one of the lessons of
the financial crisis certainties that
all market participants and got all
market products and need to attract
knowledge based assessment and we need
to protect consumers of that way so we
have a good regulatory system with
respect to our life insurance companies
and our banks through the offices who
pretend to actually citations which
reports to the people of Canada through
me is mr. advanced and anime have the
other regulatory tools that we use
regularly on a federal basis that
is put us in good shape or in the best
shape I there's any financial system in
the world right now that's certainly
what I'm hearing here at Davos who would
need to do more out of have a market
side we will put they get national
securities regulators